so at one point I heard that you were a
woman's shoe salesman
yes
like a couple years ago you know I yeah
I did a lot of jobs I cut tobacco for a
living for three dollars an hour really
sold Insurance door to door you're gonna
make me sell shoes well I just was
curious
um I have yeah
[Applause]
yeah let's see now
I'm mortified because I don't have any
self-care in my life and I'm shocked
that my legs are shaven and I shoved
nail polish on my feet guys I was
curious like I had the most disgusting
feet this morning and I was like what
was it like when some woman would sit
down and have like just corns everywhere
or like well there's a couple of things
first of all they don't take both their
shoes off usually
I mean you don't really like why not
really undressed
don't do that but uh yes we in fact why
not you gotta wear them on both feet
well exactly well you know we had this
thing that this wooden shoe horn shoe
thing that looked like Mr Potato Head
that had these holes in it and uh and a
plastic piece that would go in like Mr
Potato Head to stretch a corn into the
shoes for these for the ladies I have a
bench upstairs I should have brought
them down it's a I don't know how you
say it a corn stretcher
but you have to be careful how you
phrase these things these days like oh
my God speaking of corn my favorite one
of my favorite George stories is at the
end of Confessions of a dangerous mind
Sam is supposed to admit to me after I
just married him that he really is a CIA
assassin yes so uh
I'm like George and then my reaction as
Penny to Chuck
um is
confusion and then Preposterous laughing
like I don't know whether to believe you
or not I just can't believe this is
actually happening it's like someone
dropping the biggest bomb on you ever so
it's I'm supposed to laugh and I'm like
George I can't
I'm not a faker you know I'm just not
good at faking things I really want to
do things authentically I need to laugh
I need you're the funniest person can
you just make me laugh for real so we're
in the car me and Sam are looking each
other he admits this thing I'm having
the moment of Confusion And I just hear
George's voice corn
and of course I'm supposed to look
confused and I do look confused
and then I hear corn and
that's what's in the
what's in there you are
first of all what how does this work
exactly what size you are and you see
how but I don't know how to figure this
out why I have kids with the beer foot
oh and that's the length so you are a
well you have a little foot you're a of
you're like a five and a half is that
right I'm a well I thought it was a 7c
Oh that was much longer which is a sign
of intelligence my dad said
okay
um and then you're uh I can't see your
width here but yeah I mean you know
listen you've got a very uh very
beautiful foot really
and you tell all the ladies yes that's
I'm trying to sell shoes oh God okay
right of course all right
well I can't decide you know they're
both so interesting these are the exact
kind of shoes I was selling in 1979.
seriously no okay no I was selling these
things like they're called like
naturalizers and Clinton and they were
really for really like Dr Scholl yeah
like member Buster Browns and
unfortunately I do of course and there
was a whole generation of women this is
1979. and so there was a bunch of like
70 year old women who would get this toe
cut off
what so that they would fit into these
the pumps these really tight pumps and
so you'd anytime you saw a certain a
woman of a certain age coming in I'd be
like you take her
because women cut a toe off yeah it's
like cutting a rib out or something
right to be yeah yeah sure so if if I
yes what did you do when people were
just incredibly indecisive and like
couldn't figure it out and you're just
like make a choice
well that's a good question it's been
you know 50 years since I did it but uh
I think uh mostly you would just you
would just tell them how great
their foot looks in that shoe like gosh
you know I just can't decide well I
think this goes so well with the gray
suit
let's see
well
yeah
I'll tell you what
I think you should I think you should
get them both I I oh oh oh
that's right both they both look good on
you you know I can't decide either I'm
gonna get both good
we're gonna go to a quick commercial
break but when we come back we've got
some hot spicy fun things in the words
come back
[Applause]
[Music]